hallo willkommen zur sail ist welt viele
von euch fragen mich immer ganz gerne
selber hast du denn diese ganzen rezepte
die thema veröffentlicht nein natürlich
sind ganz viele rezepte von mir selbst
oder ich hab sie von meiner familie von
meiner mama zum beispiel vor allem diese
ganzen türkischen rezepte schulen aber
auch immer ganz gern inspirationen in
zeitschriften oder bücher oder auch mal
im internet oder ich habe einfach
freunde die zum beispiel in der
gastronomie arbeiten in der türkei holte
ich immer gerne inspirationen und ganz
viele tipps vor allem auch damit ich
eben auch alles richtig und wichtig es
auch rüberbringen kann oder eben wie
neulich in der bäckerei da war ich
nämlich in karlsruhe da hatte ich euch
auch bilder auf facebook gezeigt und auf
instagram und da habe ich eben einfach
mal zugeguckt wieder so ein brot
gebacken wird oder was eben da alles
noch mit hand gemacht wird was ich eben
auch ganz wichtig finde
und gerade das bäckereihandwerk in
deutschland ist das außergewöhnlich weil
ich glaube in keinem anderen land der
welt gibt es einfach so eine große
auswahl und so eine vielfalt an broten
und an brot kunst vor allem das ist ja
auch eine jahrhundertealte tradition die
dann immer weiter gegeben wird und
einfach eben vielfältig und richtig toll
ist und sage ich mir einfach irgendwann
die frage gestellt woran erkennt man
eigentlich ein gutes brot ein gutes brot
erkennt man daran dass eben nur zutaten
hinein kommen die auch ein gutes brot
hinein gehören ein gutes brot erkennt
man auch daran dass der bäcker so
aussieht und nicht so ein gutes brot
erkennt man auch daran dass eine hand
sind die anträge greift und die
tradition vom meister zum gesellen immer
weitergegeben wird
ein gutes brot erkennt man auch daran
dass es dort verkauft wird was gebacken
wird und nicht dort verkauft wird muss
auf gebacken wird und vorher um die
ganze welt reist ein gutes brot erkennt
man leider nicht mehr am geschmack hier
habe ich einmal echte bananen und hier
habe ich in bananen geschmack und ein
gutes brot erkennt man daran dass dort
verkauft wird wo ich eben auch gut
beraten werde
ja dann würde ich ihnen vielleicht ist
an und bieten mit dem 85 prozentigen
anteile hätte ich auch meinen frisch
durch den sauerteig oder vielleicht sein
fränkisches bauernbrot mit dem 75
prozentigen menschen die werkstätten
haben oder am stück im stück ein gutes
brot darf preiswert sein aber es darf
nicht billig sein
die frage kann ich euch beantworten nach
dem guten kuchen und deswegen nehme ich
euch jetzt einfach mal mit ich bin jetzt
in karlsruhe und zwar bei der bäckerei
hardt neben mir sitzt das egt ist
konditor und becker hier in der bäckerei
und deswegen fragt jetzt einfach mal
dass sie woran erkennt man gute buche
was ich für dich ein guter kerl ich
glaube die frage müsste ich eigentlich
oder gebe ich gerne dich zurück ist hast
du viel besser beantworten wie ich was
ist ein guter kuchen was macht ein
kuchen und guten kuchenauswahl
letztendlich ist es dass auch das was
mich interessiert also bei mir ist
natürlich immer ganz wichtig die zutaten
einfach dass ich bei mir das a und o
dann natürlich die rezeptur und
zubereitungs weise und ich hab mir jetzt
überlegt was sie ja eigentlich der profi
ist und nicht mehr so da mata der
hobbybäcker habe ich mir gedacht komm
ich geh zum city und ich habe einfach
eine idee und zwar würde ich gern mit
dir zusammen einen kuchen kreieren vom
handel strategie und sally kugel
vielleicht kommt uns da wieder was
überlegen doch idee ist die idee sehr
gut vielleicht nur seele kuchen klingt
viel schöner und ja aber das ist super
super idee das wissen wir doch mal
schauen was wir genau für den kuchen
machen oder was haben wir machen was uns
dazu einfällt
mein kenne dein blog ich glaub ich auf
allen
auf allen kuchen und torten sachen
bestens bewandert okay dann überlegen
sie etwas zusammen
ich bin ein fan der jahreszeit ich will
es abreißen
gehen jetzt eine summe nada frisch
fruchtig sein und frisch vielleicht das
auch bis exotisch sein
quark ist einer meiner lieblingssongs
mag ich auch super gerne
fotos begann
zwischen ganz ganz tolles kuchenrezepte
in seinem blog drin dass nicht nur
leicht zu backen ist und hervorragend
schmecken schöner leichter kuchen denn
wenn man den esel abhandelt zitrone
orange
ich mache aus dem handel
die
vielleicht nicht mehr
dass wir einen idealen schöner locker
leichter keks kuchen für den sommer mit
einer schönen frucht auflage aus orange
und einem schönen mantel keks boden
verein werttransporter einmal genau so
schlau probiere das ist einfach auch mal
einfach mal los gehen
als otto kurve nicht fertig für mich
sieht er richtig perfekt aus vor allem
dieter halt einfach handgemacht aus also
wie aus dem eigenen backofen daheim ist
natürlich jetzt ein richtig guter kuchen
denn das soll ja auch gutes bewirke und
wir haben uns überlegt dass man den
kuchen zusammen verkaufen
seid ihr verkauft den bereichen die
filiale und ich möchte damit ein
soziales projekt unterstützen wir
unterstütze dabei aber auch gemeinsam
ihr handwerk und so diese dieses bäcker
und konditor handwerk und aber immer
noch genau eine server fehlt noch was
ganz wichtig ist für uns damit er auch
gut weil jedem zuhause ankommt das ist
eine tolle verpackung und da habe ich
schon ein bisschen was vorbereitet wie
das so im fernsehen vor sich geht
einen wunderbaren silly karton genau
richtig schön rosa also der fast zu mir
mit meinem logo natürlich drauf los
wir sagen perfekt
ab
so sieht unser kurdisch gebacken die
verpackung mich auch da und ich bin
total begeistert was wir hier zusammen
geschaffen haben wir gemeinsam diesen
käse kuchen gebacken mit einer leckeren
orangen schicht und haben ja lange
verlegt was die zusammenarbeit könne und
sind auf den käse kommen weil du ja auf
meinem blog auf diese stadt
abgeschlossen wird
genau das war eine ganz tolle sache ich
hab das rezept gesehen ich hab's
vorgebacken in der zeitung war so
begeistert davon dass gesagt das muss es
sein und der caseking ist ja die königin
der kuchen
also von daher hat ist es ja einiges
ideale produkt das wir zusammen backen
konnten und wir haben noch ein bisschen
verfeinert ist ein ganz leckeren wandel
boden
unten den wir gemacht haben haben sie
ein bisschen variiert haben gesagt okay
wir können wie können wir den kuchen
noch besser machen müssen optimieren wie
so optimieren auch ein bisschen
fruchtiger für den sommer direkten
produkt für den sommer kreieren das ist
jetzt geworden
ich bin auch restlos begeistert vor
allem ist es ja auch im kuchen den man
einfach kaufen kann und einfach zwei
drei vier tage essen kann also das war
ja auch unser hauptargument dass man
jetzt sagen wir machen keine sahne torte
die dann an einem tag nach einem tag
gleich kaputt geht weil wir wollten ja
keine geschmacksverstärker mit drin
haben wir wollen ja keine
konservierungsstoffe mit drin alles ganz
natürlich und deswegen zimmer auf diesen
keks kuchen gekommen
ich finde es super dass du mich
unterstützt hat dass wir dieses rezept
noch ein bisschen optimiert haben vor
allem die orangen sich perfekt für den
sommer richtig schön fruchtig frisch und
ja ich bin das nicht der perfekte
sommer gucken und es toll ist natürlich
auch wenn in dieser schicht nicht
marshall an viele mit drin
das heißt es ist einfach ein
pflanzliches mittel mit verarbeitet
worden wir achten natürlich sehr stark
darauf was für rohstoffe wie einsetzen
es war uns auch sehr wichtig und du hast
gesagt ja das soll ein paar tage halten
ich bezweifle dass der ein paar tage
helden ist so lecker denn man am stück
essen wollen
und ich glaube das war ja auch sinn und
zweck der sache wissen ganz legaler
mandl boden geworden denn wieder
verwendet haben ist eine ganz lockere
luftige käse schicht hier mit etwas
saures noch mitreden das ganze sehr
schmackhaft macht die wirklichen
gelungenes produkt ja finde es auch vor
allem werde ich ja oft gefragt verlief
wo kann man einen kuchen kaufen kann ich
sie nicht bei ihr bestellen und ich muss
noch immer sagen nie leider gibt es bei
mir halt gar nicht und das war halt so
freundlich unser leben gekommen lasst
uns doch mal zusammen ein projekt
starten zusammen was backen und das hat
jetzt in der hauptfiliale verkaufen
deswegen bin ich dir da ganz dankbar
dass wir zusammen machen können
genau man muss noch ein bisschen
gedulden aber demnächst werden wir es in
unseren läden exklusiv an machen
anbieten ist eine ganz tolle geschichte
und katholische auffällig man sieht dein
gesicht drauf also mehr so ein karton
hat auch eigentlich gar nicht mehr den
kuchen essen wollen ich glaube allein
der karton ist eine augenweide ist ganz
toll geworden
wir werden das ganze demnächst bei uns
in der filiale anbieten fälle zum
anfassen zum anbeißen
wer weiß vielleicht falle unser noch ein
paar rezepte mehr ein grausamer kreieren
können dass ich einfach mal so ein start
und ich denke das wird eine ganz tolle
geschichte
vor allem weil wir halt auch das
handwerk unterstützt
und einfach so eine neue idee mit rein
gebracht haben als nächstes ist der
perfekte kuchen und butterkuchen weil er
bei mir ja auch gutes bewirkt denn ich
möchte ja so habe ich mir das überlegt
meinem gewinn also meinen anteil direkt
komplett spenden an ein soziales projekt
und vielleicht habt ihr auch bei euch in
der umgebung polizei oder beckereit eben
auch so das richtige handwerk noch
unterstützt noch richtig packt und
könnte mir einfach mal schreiben
vielleicht möchten die außen projekt
unterstütze dass mir das so was machen
kann
ich finde super geschichte vor allem hat
viel spaß gemacht hier
ich finde es schön dass es sie gebe mich
dabei unterstützt hat und ich finde es
klasse
ja ich denke man wird vieles noch von
der aktion mitbekommen und ich denke es
wird echt ein toller erfolg wird davon
überzeugt genau man danke ich euch fürs
zuschauen und wünsche euch viel spaß vor
allem in guten appetit
bis dann